you
all right what's going on everybody
happy or good evening afternoon I guess
if you're on the west coast this is
possibly the last stream for a while
just kind of waiting around for traffic
out of Boston to die down big travel day
before Thanksgiving so I'm gonna do some
streaming and have a bunch of stuff to
talk about including some of the things
that will be on tomorrow's show so
welcome I am once again live
simultaneously both on youtube and on
Twitch and I am already being attacked
for competing with different shows I
don't watch anything so I have no clue
when any show airs like people are
telling me I'm on with the The Young
Turks are on I've never I didn't know
what time they were on so apologies in
advance for everything I did wrong
and hopefully we can still talk about a
bunch of different stuff I am going to
talk about Melania Trump brutally booed
at an opioid summit and we have the
video and I don't feel bad at all I
don't and I'm gonna explain to you why
momentarily I also want to look in more
detail at this full weird dog press
conference that Trump had where
everything about it was weird and it's
clear Trump doesn't know or know
anything about or like dogs and it's
just all very very strange I also then
have a bunch of clips of Tucker Carlson
where first he says something really
weird then he sort of tries to make up
for it with the clarification and then
Fox today had a guest on Michael Blake I
believe his name is who absolutely
destroyed Tucker and it really angered
host Bill Hemmer and we're going to have
these videos so a lot of a lot of
different things to discuss here and I'm
looking forward to doing it with you I
will do my best to answer both super
chats over on YouTube as well as
messages that come in with various
twitch prime and and tier one through
three subscriptions over on Twitch and I
should be able to keep up with
everything these afternoon
late afternoon early evening streams
they don't tend to get super crazy so I
think we're gonna have plenty of time to
look at all of this stuff for people
asking so on Sunday night I did a I did
we did a contest between YouTube and
twitch viewers where we had a coupon
code youtube over on twit on youtube and
then we didn't really have like a twitch
specific coupon code and people were
furious and they said that this was me
showing deference to YouTube or
something like that
so I have created a new coupon code for
my website it's twitch fifty I'll talk
about it a little bit later but it's
enabled and we will do a similar
competition today YouTube vs twitch
YouTube 50 is the Utah Youtube coupon
code twitch 50 is the twitch coupon code
and then we'll see if that does anything
for us or not okay let's get right into
this so Donald Trump has been getting
booed at a lot of different places he
went to world 5 of Game five of the
Baseball World Series a few weeks ago
brutally booed went to a UFC event in
New York City Madison Square Garden
brutally booed then he went over to
Alabama to a football game did not get
booed there reportedly and he finally
found a friendly crowd so in any case
Melania Trump booed in Baltimore First
Lady Melania Trump took her be best
initiative now let me briefly talk about
be best because this is already
something please tell me in the chat
whether I'm accurately understanding
this I was under the impression that
when Melania Trump said be best it was a
completely grammatically incorrect
spur-of-the-moment thing that she said
during an interview where she was asked
one of these throwaway questions like
you know what's your message to people
or you know you're against bullying like
what would you say what and she said my
message would be be best and she's not a
native English speaker and I think it
was just like a grammatical mistake but
I guess they had to go with it like when
Trump tweeted cob feffy and Sean Spicer
said oh no no no that has a meaning and
people who were in there's like an in
crowd that understands what that means
they had to go with it I I think that
they're going with this be best thing
merely to not admit that she just
misspoke because English is
her first language but needless to say
first Lady Melania Trump took her be
best initiative to Baltimore she was met
with a chorus of boos from attendees at
a use thumbin Youth Summit aimed at
raising awareness about the nation's
opioid crisis the heckling lasted for
about one minute but the audience
remained raucous audibly speaking over
her remarks throughout her brief speech
to be more youth summit undeterred she
pressed on so let's take a look at the
video oh I I have video but I do see
people saying that the Alabama students
were threatened if that if they booed
they'd be banned from games or removed
I almost reported that but then it came
out that that wasn't actually true it
seems that they said if they were it
seemed it was more about harassing other
students for their political views or
something like that
but in any case let's take a look at the
video let's listen to what happened
[Applause]
whoo
yeah that that is mostly boo
[Applause]
oh dear
for people pointing out but you can
simultaneously not feel bad but it but
recognize it's not her fault and I see
people in both the YouTube and twitch
chat saying it's not her fault it's not
I mean listen it was her choice as far
as we know to marry Donald Trump and
presumably she had some say in whether
Trump would run for president but no it
is not her fault
but let's not feel bad for people in you
know extreme positions of privilege
first for something like this of course
you know if her father came down with an
illness we would all feel bad I'm not
saying that we were all right well let's
skip ahead to when she talks
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I thought yeah that's pretty brutal
and so hit listen here's the thing she
is a part of one of the most destructive
presidencies that we've seen and but you
know she's not these aren't physical
attacks nobody is saying necessarily
that she's a bad person although you
know agreeing to be with Donald Trump
certainly raises questions but it give
me a break like what I I don't even
understand why someone would say hey
here's an idea
let's get Melania Trump to speak about
something it just doesn't really make
any sense to me so you know booing is
people who are going to say it's it's
impolite okay maybe it is but almost
everything that Donald Trump has done is
impolite and destructive and whatever
like the we're talking about adults
wealthy adults with full-time security
and whatever she got booed she's she's
an adult I think that she can handle it
that's generally my view I don't know if
anybody has a different view it seems on
Twitch people are saying that the booing
is fine although it's not her fault
in other words if she weren't Trump's
wife she wouldn't be getting booed more
than likely the same time if she weren't
Trump's wife I don't know that she
speaks about opiates but that's sort of
another question altogether yeah it
seems most folks are saying that that
that's their that's their view on this
so there it is Melania Trump booed
brutally at an event I'm not even going
to cover this on tomorrow's show which
is our last show before Thanksgiving
just because you know I think it would
it's relatively predictable that this is
exactly what would happen let me read a
few Super chats over on YouTube rapid
burrito says it makes sense to give this
free YouTube money to progressive thanks
YouTube rapid burrito again last one
you're amazing David thank you yeah the
free super chats I guess available still
and for a couple more days to anyone
with YouTube premium one other super
chat and it is from my name who says
only take my you to take my free YouTube
money thank you
I appreciate that okay let's get to the
next thing I talked on the show today a
little bit about this oh and thank you
overrun twitch staff at Manchac for the
twitch prime sub and Geetha rabbit for
two months in a row with twitch prime I
appreciate that so Donald Trump does not
have he has not shown signs of being
empathetic to anyone or anything that
I've ever seen his relationship to his
kids are weird he doesn't really seem to
like Tiffani at all and I guess he's
sort of is okay with Barron I don't know
but in any case everything is about
Trump and everything around Trump is a
prop like Melania is effectively a prop
pence is a prop he appealed to
evangelicals it's all props around
Donald Trump the war criminals that he
pardoned now he wants them to campaign
for Trump because he sees them as props
campaign props so check out this very
bizarre press conference with this dog
dog the dog is Conan
I guess Trump calls it Conan and
everything about his body language the
things he sits at he doesn't really
understand what a dog is it seems like
let's take a listen he said he mentions
this particular type thing multiple
times but never mentions the type he
knows it's a type of dog what type
though he's not going to be able to tell
us it's praying that if you open your
mouths you will be attacked
Coenen came over from the middle-east
just arrived with some of the great
people from the Special Forces so Payton
remember pay attention to that the dog
just arrived from the Middle East okay
so the person in question died by
suicide important today is gone that was
a flawless attack and I just met quite a
few of them and we just gave Conan a
medal and a plaque right and dogs love
plaque see and I actually think Conan
knew exactly what was going on but a dog
that is very very special and yeah
listen I don't know a thing about dogs
maybe somebody else could say something
that has some semblance of coherence
so I guess no one's going to say
anything but pence will touch the dog
because Trump and Melania are just
staring at it like it's not even human
not like it's not even alive they put a
muzzle on the dog and I thought that was
a good idea but then it gets even more
violent it's also kind of weird like any
any dog
forget about dog owner like I don't own
a dog but I know that you know you you
don't want to stigmatize dogs as violent
and it's not the instinct of dogs to be
violent some dogs are trained in a
particular way including to deal with
situations where there is violence but
even like the weird joking about how
violent and vicious this dog is is weird
genius it actually does better it reads
and does math much better than Trump
that was with the special forces people
that it works with and for obvious
reasons they can't be out but they did a
fantastic job Conan did a fantastic job
and we're very honored to have Conan
here and giving Conan a certificate and
an award this is the second time by the
way that he's asked Mike to say
something and I and the first time no
one said anything I don't know if the
handler is Mike or he was referring to
Mike Pence but this is the second time
he's called for Mike to say something
meeting with some of the very same
Special Forces who completed a
successful raid that took down the
leader of Isis I recall mr. president
when you made the decision right up
there in the White House the day before
the raid you had talked about measures
that were available to protect our
soldiers and didn't describe to us about
the fact that they had dogs that could
go in in the event that Outback Daddy
had on him a explosive vest right that
you put the premium on the safety of our
Special Forces and this dog was there
suffered some injury we were able to
complete the rain without any American
casualty and so I think which is all we
care about apparently having the Special
Forces here today who obviously can't
come out in the public yeah so two two
things that a lot of people in both the
YouTube chat and the twitch chat are
saying number one Trump is obviously not
listening to what Mike Pence is saying
and number two Trump is doing this weird
thing where he stands well so we'll talk
about the standing in a bit but he is
he's doing a particular thing yeah Conan
is really a hero it's a real joy to be
able to help
Coenen was very badly hurt as you know
and they thought maybe was not going to
recover recovered actually very quickly
and has since gone on very important
trades as you know we captured 100
percent of the Isis Caliphate is it
could that be true that since the al
Baghdady raid the dog was injured
recovered and has since been on multiple
raids hasn't it only been like three
weeks and the dog hasn't the dog also
been in Washington for like ten days
though they were just forming again and
now it's a hundred percent we have done
a lot of work since then we have done a
lot of work since the raid certain
things have happened that are very
important we've had a lot of help too
from other countries yeah we really done
a job I just want to thank you all so
this is a special time for Conan and we
really appreciate it and I was told
about at the breed I was told about
again it's a type of dog it's a breed of
dog but we don't know what it is I asked
one question I said so what chance with
Conan I got to see how fast the Dakota
can move I said what chance with a
strong man have really strong tough
fighter what chance would this person
have against Conan without the guns
what chance and I guess the answer
pretty much was none he would have no
chance right so it's amazing and yet you
see how beautiful and how calm during a
situation like this is Trump just
earlier said that if they if they if
they merely put a muzzle on the dog it
becomes vicious but then now he's
talking about how calm the dog is
mood today Jeff not a bad mood you're
safe anyway so I want to thank you all
thank you very much and it's a great
honor to have Conan here a great honor
to have the special forces here their
tone is not retiring yet
Conan's primetime age-wise front guy I
asked that question they go for about
six years they go for six years they
start they'd like to get them at one and
a half or two years old and they'll go
for about six years from that time after
that it happens where maybe the reflexes
aren't quite as good you know but the
dog primetime is those six years after -
and they're very special dogs are very
hard to get just regular dog is this is
the again third time he's alluding to
this particular type of dog and nobody
knows what he doesn't know what it is
what whoa what just happened ultimate
everything ultimate in terms of sniffing
drugs we have we spent a tremendous
amount of money on drug equipment at the
border yeah
so listen he just told us the dogs been
working in the Middle East for a long
time and now he says this is a great dog
for sniffing drugs at the border like
what what what is he talking about
talking to the people I say well is
there anything better than this
equipment no sir the only thing better
is a dog a dog this type of dog exactly
exactly this type of dog which for the
fourth time I'm unable to identify the
cylinder of a car all right so it's very
very weird I think we've probably seen
enough so let me talk now about the
Trump standing thing because a lot of
people have pointed this out yeah let me
find an example of this I think I've got
it here a bunch of people have pointed
out to me that Trump stands in a really
weird way that sort of seems to defy
what we sort of know of as the physics
of bipedal locomotion which is this
right here it's it's I don't believe
that this has been edited but it is very
odd and I guess I can't see the full
thing let me see if I can zoom it out a
little bit let's see yeah there we go
like there there is something strange
about the way that he's standing there
and it does you would imagine that maybe
there were there was some kind of rope
underneath his armpits that was holding
him from falling forward or something
like that it is a really really weird
thing I don't know what people can make
of that but it is I guess he was sort of
doing it you know from the front you
often can't tell but it is a very weird
thing and it does seem to his like the
bottom part of his leg seems to be
concave I don't even know if that's the
right word and then it you know I mean I
think people understand what's going on
it's not obvious often looking from the
front but yeah here he's sort of doing
it again it's it does seem like he's
leaning forward in a very particular way
it's happening here although maybe here
he's kind of leaning on justin trudeau
unclear about that yeah by the way
Justin Trudeau as far as we know is six
- Trump claims to be 6-3 and that does
not seem to be the truth so really weird
yeah really weird stuff but most notable
in this one and it's all very very
strange okay let me say some thank yous
because I do see people who have been
signing up over on Twitch Prime and so
on and so forth let me say thank you to
bride clutches for subscribing for four
months at Tier one thank you Slingblade
nine nine nine thanks for the twitch
prime sub over on YouTube a few super
chats have come in let me see here
don't want to miss anything and we got
very very involved there in some of
these images Paul Jacobi says so he
can't think of the breed name yeah
apparently Trump doesn't know what kind
of dog that is it I believe it's a
Belgian Malinois right
I'm not a dog expert Paul Jacobi also
saying his United States dementia mouth
again I didn't notice that during that
speech actually Paul but certainly no
shortage of instances of that okay and
let me also say thank you to jab it J
bin Alan Jabin Alan has signed up using
the twitch fifty coupon code that is new
member number one of fifteen but that
also puts twitch in the lead one-nothing
so okay here's what's going on people
are asking what is this twitch verses
YouTube thing so we're live on both
twitch and YouTube right now last Sunday
we did a contest between the twitch
viewers and the YouTube viewers where
YouTube viewers were directed to sign up
with a YouTube has the coupon code
youtube my website join pakman.com saves
you 50% twitch has the coupon code now
twitch fifty which we didn't have last
week we had a generic one last week and
last or Sunday Sunday YouTube one I
think it was like 11 to 1 over twitch it
was a really bad it was it was not good
it was really really not good
and a lot of people said you know the
problem David is you didn't really have
a twitch code you sort of like gave us
this BS code that was already in
existence and it doesn't feel like you
care about twitch so we actually today
have a code which is twitch 50 so right
now twitch is actually in the lead
one-nothing either way if we get to 15
new members I'll open the phone lines
and we had some great calls in fact
there were two calls from last week from
last Sunday that we are turning into
YouTube clips which will publish over
the Thanksgiving break because they were
very very interesting okay
let's go on to the next thing let's talk
about Tucker Carlson Tucker Carlson is a
Fox News host he has previously said
things like immigrants make our country
dirtier and white supremacy is a hoax
okay
so he said I guess this was on last
night's show that he is rooting for
Russia against Ukraine what that means
is
but let's listen to it and see if we can
figure out what it is that he meant no
matter might not actually like color
Weiden but that's totally corrupt and
you know it why is it worse to ask about
it than it is to do it because people
are dying on the front lines do you
think it's a job in the conflict between
Ukraine and watch in that route for
Russia which I am because those of us
who are watching myself who think
democracy preserving democracy is
important when dictate so then he went
to break and then I guess the feedback
started coming in that you know it
doesn't really sound too good for you to
say that you are supporting Russia over
Ukraine so then at the close of the show
I guess after he checked in with trace
Gallagher he kind of clarifies that I
guess that was a joke even though he
said I'm serious right before it trace
Gallagher the great Chris Gallagher
thank you
right time right before we go earlier in
the show I noted that I was rooting for
Russia in the contest between Russia and
Ukraine of course I'm joking I'm only
rooting for America mocking the trace
there is so anyway so that was weird to
begin with then today Fox invites what
was this guy's name Michael Blake I
believe this is who's the DNC Vice Chair
and also a New York State Assemblyman
and the question is here's what Tucker
Carlson said what do you think so
Michael Blake goes right after Tucker
Carlson and the host Bill Hemmer doesn't
like it and it gets beautifully awkward
intense check this out mama let's be
honest is one of the only people who
could unite the parties warring factions
Tucker Carlson with a bold prediction
saying Michelle Obama just may be the
Democratic ticket next year despite the
former first lady saying she's not
interested Michael Blake vice chair of
the DNC in a New York State Assembly
minute how you doing Mike nice to see
you sir what did make of the prediction
on Michelle Obama like to see that well
she's not running but the core question
is why the hell does talk of cars still
have a job here the reality is this is
someone who said white supremacy is a
hoax and why does watts allow mr.
be here in the first place well I'm in
his opinion there is that Michelle Obama
may get in this race do you think that
will happen or is nothing not going to
happen on it not gonna happen but I
think the the core question is he
shouldn't be on here at all yeah we
didn't bring you on to talk about Tucker
Carlson you kind of did I mean you
played you played a video you played a
video of what Tucker Carlson said and
said excuse me please respond this it's
sort of like if I went on a show and
they played a video of Richard Spencer
commenting about what type of Apple he
likes I probably wouldn't just respond
about the Apple I'd point out you know
this is one of the most toxic white
nationalists in the country who has
bamboozled a lot of people with his sort
of you know elegant white nationalism
and packet I wouldn't just say well I
like here's the type of Apple that I
like and I don't agree so so this is
this is instance number one and again
Bill Hemmer says I didn't bring you on
to talk about Tucker you kind of did you
brought me on to respond to a clip of
Tucker Carlson I just didn't respond to
it in the way that you wanted so then it
gets even better where it tries to go on
he tries to go on to other topics and
again Michael Blake talks about Tucker
Carlson it's we're talking about jobs
while Trump is ignoring the truth we're
talking about health care why he's
ignoring the truth and the question must
be for Donald Trump for Fox News for
other entities and I can bash our
network so do respect why don't we just
keep it on topic but it's not political
magazine says this just out no it's not
well the it is yeah it's relevant to the
conversation we're having save it for
later political magazine it says later
when Twitter waiting for Obama here's
the quote out just a moment ago with one
candidate he meaning Barack Obama
pointed out that during his own 2008
campaign he had an intimate bond with
the electorate especially in Iowa that
he no longer has then he added and you
know who really doesn't have it Joe
Biden end quote there your reaction to
that
so first it's not appropriate just to
say that we can't talk about we should
say you brought us on to be a guest
second the question around the
electorate and the an effort one of the
reasons you brought me on is that was a
part of the team that organized a
successful election in 2008 and
thereafter so when it comes to the
coalition's yes
everyone should be talking about
mobilizing coalition's black white
Latino Native American Asian etc not
just Joe Biden but all the candidates in
the field we are talking about uniting
of races as others are talk about
dividing a racist and so it is always
appropriate to bring up these issues as
one of the reason you brought the
comment was you know who really doesn't
have it Jill Biden do you agree with
that no no because the reality is if we
take things just out of context rather
the broader conversations all these
candidates are in the field even you
look at the Fox News polls last week
they're defeating Donald Trump so it's
hard to say to someone doesn't have it
if they're clearly winning in the
battleground states you know I see in
these polls that it appears that it
seems like at this point he doesn't go
back to attacking Fox News but so here's
one of the things you have to understand
that was really good and we're gonna out
play some clips of that on the broadcast
show tomorrow and I see the super chats
coming in I'm gonna get to those and I'm
gonna get to the twitch prime thank-yous
as well there's this sort of unspoken
thing when you go on certain networks I
mean really what what our propaganda
networks right where when you go on Fox
News and you're from the left you can
attack the guest you can go after the
president you can do right you're doing
that stuff because you're playing the
role of the leftist but if you attack
hosts or you go after the place that Fox
News has in the propaganda sphere you're
sort of you're breaking the unwritten
rule and it's very interesting because
nobody has ever that I know of I've been
a guest on Fox News and I know many
people who have I'm not aware of anyone
who's been told you can't attack the
network but when people have done it
they've never been invited back it's a
similar thing on RT the Russian
television channel where you can get
invited on you can be from the left you
can be come from the right you can talk
about propaganda in some vague way or
whatever but if you go on and you
actually attack RT you you're breaking
that unwritten rule which is you're not
supposed to do that you know and and
you're not as far as I know invited back
I don't know if it's the same thing like
on al Jazeera for example but this is
it's sort of an unspoken thing that is a
very common you just not supposed to do
it go after whatever but you're not
supposed to do that and clearly Michael
Blake doing a hell
a job a hell of a job here ya know
people who are saying in the chat who
cares it was worth it I completely agree
with you
I completely agree who cannot invited
back
for the twitches Prime subscription and
sans Sumer one for the second month in a
row twitch Prime subscription if you
have questions for me by all means send
them for example via YouTube super chat
one example is strong moon one who says
what is Obama's last name I mean I don't
know if this is some trick but as far as
I know it's it's Obama a JC sent a
message but then retracted it I wonder
what that's about
ARS longa says yes it is a Belgian
Malinois yeah we were talking about this
we were talking about this dog and
apparently it is a Belgian Malinois very
nice dog
another super chat from 5th calibre who
sends a $20 super chat and says you are
amazing thank you I appreciate that very
very much let me also say thanks to
Craig Forres Craig Flores has signed up
on join pakman.com using the coupon code
youtube hi it's a very weak tie it's
one-to-one between the youtube coupon
code and the twitch coupon code we are
live on both YouTube and twitch and we
have the coupon code youtube my website
for youtube viewers and the coupon code
twitch 50 over on twitch and last sunday
twitch got defeated like 10 to 1 or
something like that it's 1 to 1 right
now people are asking are we going to
open the phone lines and it we may if we
get to 15 new members but it would be
nice to have more of a battle between
twitch and youtube than the very
lopsided situation that we had the other
day ok so I got those are a few things
let me pull up I had a few other things
I wanted to go over with you before
things get too out of hand let me find a
lot of my things have moved around here
ok let me just pull up my
it's so many thing and by the way if
people also have things that they want
me to discuss or videos to go over I'm
glad to do that I should have been
better prepared here oh okay the Michael
Bloomberg ads yeah so I got a bunch of
messages saying David you've got to look
at Michael Bloomberg's ads and also
Michael Bloomberg's speeches because
each is more boring than than the last
one so let's see what we can find
Michael Bloomberg first let's do speech
I guess these were recent ones where it
was just like terrible yeah this is the
one right here like the the most
uninspiring possible thing is what I
heard that's in everyone it's great to
be here it seems to be coming out only
I'm only hearing out of the left ear but
that seems to be an issue that is beyond
my control and let me start by saying I
was glad to support Nancy's campaign for
the House of Delegates she is going to
be a strong leader on the big issues
facing this community and the whole
state including climate change and I'm
happy to also say that I supported 14
other Virginia Democrats who also won
election thanks to the good work of so
many volunteers and supporters who
knocked on doors and make me say he
seems to have a Boston accent is Michael
Bloomberg from Boston let's see Michael
Bloomberg Brighton Massachusetts okay I
didn't realize that that took me by
surprise all right let's continue I know
that we're only getting audio out of one
ear it's it's the video it's not
anything I'm doing odors to the polls
and in January Democrats will take
charge of the state government for the
first time in 25 years it's about time
in 19 or in 2018 I also supported two
congressional candidates here in
Virginia who won jennifer Wexton and
elaine Lauria who represents this part
of the area and the surrounding place
their strong campaigns helped the
democrats capture the US House of
Representatives and began holding
president Trump accountable for his
dangerous abuse of power and I think
that's one of the good news yeah pretty
uninspiring so far let's skip ahead a
little
we have a climate change that is growing
worse by the day and we have special
interests that corrupt Washington and
block progress on all of these issues as
a child and a boy scout I was taught to
believe in the promise and potential of
America and I've never been more worried
about its future than I am today
yikes America is at its best when we
work together to find meaningful and
lasting solutions to our big challenges
mmm weed a president who understands
that truth and who can do it rather than
just make promises yeah I don't know who
would see this and go you know what
there's nobody already in the field that
however many people are officially
running there's just nobody that I could
imagine voting for but now that Mike
Bloomberg's running he's really inspired
I mean it just it's a total lack of
charisma let's let's skip ahead a little
more someone with the experience to hit
the ground ready to go I am that person
and that's why I'm running who I will be
the only candidate in this race who
isn't going to take a penny from anyone
and will work for a dollar a year just
as I did for 12 years in New York City
Hall over the course of this campaign I
will tell you what I'll do as president
and how I will do it yeah but not
tonight
okay yeah this is pretty bad this is
this is really pretty uninspiring let's
check out his ad and see I'm not
actually seeing any new ads from Michael
Bloomberg here rebuild him okay Ellis
here's one let's take a look at it Mike
Bloomberg started as a middle-class kid
who had to work his way through college
then built a business from a single room
to a global entity creating tens of
thousands of good-paying jobs along the
way he could have stopped there but when
New York suffered the terrible tragedy
of 9/11 he took charge becoming a
three-term mayor who brought a city back
from the ashes and brought back jobs and
hoped with it creating tens of thousands
of affordable housing units so families
could have a decent place to live
raising teachers salaries and kids
graduation right man Eve even the ad
there's something uninspiring about it I
don't know so here's what I think is
really behind what's going on here if
you look at like Elizabeth Warren's
wealth tax and you can actually click if
you're Michael Bloomberg click here he
would over three billion next year under
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax now I've
said I don't think her wealth tax passes
certainly not as conceived right now but
there's a lot of reason to believe that
even if he has to invest a billion of
his own money to prevent Bernier Warren
from winning it might actually be you
know a reasonable investment for him to
make just because of what what is
potentially at stake and we know
Bloomberg really has a lot of money like
Trump Trump has a lot of money and we
don't know it he claims I think they
have three or four billion it could be
less I don't know but Bloomberg has you
know 25 times 20 times the money that
Donald Trump has and I think that just
this exposes a lot a lot a lot of what's
going on because he's got no shot at
winning and if he spent you know 50
million a hundred million a billion of
his own money to help the Democratic
nominee win that would do way more to
defeat Trump then
Bloomberg trying to be the nominee I
just don't see it it doesn't make sense
to me at all and this could explain a
lot of it let me say thank you to
dinosaur chol for subscribing for the
fourth month in a row on twitch spirit
14 thank you for the subscription nix
the ladder thank you son Sumer thank you
for the second month in a row and thanks
to March Road for subscribing with
twitch prime over on YouTube if people
have questions by all means send me a
super chat Trinity Trinity Jones asking
am I free for a date you know I'm not
Trinity I'm not I apologize for that
Ben I says did you see that tulsi is on
Joe Rogan again today I did not
I did not see that but I appreciate you
letting me know a DD says if bernie is
elected how long to make Medicare for
all a reality oh boy do I really want to
do this right now
so here's the thing this is just when a
president when a presidential candidate
outlines their platform it's a set of
ideas and a lot of the things are not
going to become policy as proposed and
that doesn't mean that they're bad ideas
and it doesn't mean that the person
proposing the ideas is a bad person or
is dishonest but when you look at
something like Medicare for all in in
all likelihood the next president will
not have a Democratic Senate after 2020
it's possible got to flip about five
seats and some of them are tough ones to
flip maybe could get one in 2022 and a
lot of the Democrats that would have to
go along with Medicare for all don't
support Medicare for all now this is not
my view this is just the reality so to
your question of if bernie is elected
how long to make Medicare for all a
reality I don't think it's going to
happen as proposed I think it's going to
be a starting point and I think it's
worth having it as the starting point
and I support it but I think that we end
up in the best case during the next term
if we get a Democratic president and you
get the Senate you get a negotiation
that pulls us to the left but I I don't
you know the the political practically I
don't want to I know people will say Oh
David you're just wrong you're being
defeatist this is how politics works but
you didn't you don't just get everything
you propose and Medicare for all is a
really big thing there will be a lot of
forces that have power acting against it
and it's going to be you know it's gonna
be a fight so I don't have an answer for
you unfortunately
Rock Lee says donate to Steve Cox for
Senate vs. Mitch McConnell now what
about Amy McGrath or is Steve
it's Steve Cox a Republican challenger
because Amy McGrath is ditch Mitch
McConnell independent okay yeah I don't
know anything about this guy but that's
interesting I'll check that out
let's see what other super chats there
are Joey B says in Spanish gracias por
todo thank you I appreciate that
and Madison 2019 says do you believe Fox
News and conservative networks brainwash
people you know I don't know if it's a
literal brainwashing but they certainly
prey on people who lack the critical
thinking skills to independently sort of
analyze or think about what it is that's
being presented to them no question
about that whatsoever John Harris says
Bloomberg / yang I don't know if that's
a joke but I don't think that's gonna
happen
Ryan nawicki says via super chat Supreme
Court recently said they want to revive
non delegation doctrine relating to
future regulations in a way which gives
them some veto powers what are your
thoughts have not looked into it and
would not want to comment until I have
an informed opinion Elm aw tree says
free super chats leggo Louis emo says I
thought Bloomberg would be more frisky
don't know what you mean by that
don't know what they mean by that ARS
longa says please do a show on RT i used
to appear on RT and I stopped and I
don't think I would at this point and
they don't invite me anyway so I don't
think it's gonna happen how do we get
out of this two-party system ran hold or
57 asks well one of the things we have
to do is we need a system that won't
punish voters if they vote third party
by making it more likely that the person
they really don't like becomes president
and unfortunately the spoiler effect is
a very very real thing right now fav one
says will trump be impeached and removed
will he resign before that happens or
will he make it to 2020 I believe Trump
makes it to the 2020 election and I
don't know if he wins re-election but I
believe that Trump definitely makes it
to the 2020 election the hemp hog
chronic says wow you're going to skip
my free money super chat eh I didn't see
it I apologize Russell Jones says do you
think it would be smart for Buddha judge
to name a woman of color as
vice-president early on to make inroads
I don't know what it would be smart for
Buddha judge to do and I shouldn't
advise him because he's doing something
right and I don't understand what it is
let's look at some recent polling oh by
the way a lot of people asking in the
chat who's winning
twitch versus YouTube right now it's
still one to one it's very very slow so
I'll keep you posted on that if if
anything else happens so there's a
recent poll which has Buddha judge at
sixteen sixteen and that's the little
pop that you see down here which gets
Buddha judge up to almost ten percent
nationally I find Pete Buddha judge to
be one of the most boring flavors of
centrism that exists in the Democratic
Party and I really hope that this does
not go the distance but he is look I
mean if we look at Iowa Buddha judge is
well ahead in Iowa if the last three
polls can be believed if you look at New
Hampshire Buddha judge is either right
in there as you can see here or leading
according to the st. Anselm poll from a
few days ago Nevada
I think he's doing nothing Nevada yeah
so he's got no shot in Nevada right now
but of course if he wins the first - who
knows what what that'll what will happen
there and then South Carolina he has
even less of a chance and I you know he
doesn't seem to be doing well with black
voters I don't believe the reason is
that black voters are homophobic I'm
trying to remember who said that to me
there was appeared on some show and the
person said oh the reason Buddha judge
isn't doing well with black voters is
because they're homophobic I don't
remember where that is where that was
but in any case Pete Buddha judge is
doing something right and you know one
of the things is he certainly is being
helped by establishment media MSNBC
giving Peter Judge much more screen time
than you would expect on the basis of
how he was polling then
and I think it's bad I'm not I'm not a
mayor Pete guy and I have some friends
who are and I don't think I don't think
it's a good thing let me say thank you
to Ma
Mott so who's subscribed over on Twitch
with twitch Prime the funds one has
subscribed for four months in a row and
says thank you for providing a
progressive platform feel free to
include questions in your twitch prime
subscriptions because I'm getting them
from YouTube via super chat and I'm glad
to grab some from twitch as well but I
appreciate that thing Oh Sam that's
right it's so funny people people in the
chat know more about what's been said on
my show mojo 86 says it was Sam Harris
who said that on your show that's right
somehow we got into this Sam Harris and
I and he said I believe Pete Budaj
is not doing well with black voters
because they're homophobic and I don't
believe that that is that is the case
yeah thank you for pointing that out
let me see other there's a few other
messages I wanted to get to you here
dreadlocks says if the goal of
impeachment is to damage Trump's
reelection do you think they're moving
too fast eventually they have to take it
to the Senate where it'll die listen I
mean the question is if they we don't
know if there's going to be more
hearings I think there should be Trump's
attorney Don McGann now he has been told
he has to testify he can still show up
and invoke executive privilege to every
question but I think that there should
be more testimony and if that's the case
the answer will be no they're not
actually moving too fast but it remains
to be seen
the hemp hog chronic says what would you
think about Nina Turner for Bernie's
vice presidential pick my Republican
friends say Tulsi would be the best who
would you like to see I'm not even gonna
get into VP yet I have no opinion about
Nina Turner I am NOT a fan of Tulsi so I
don't I don't know that that's what I
want to want what I want to see happen
Sid Baretta says via super chat Mayo
Pete makes me physically nauseous any
thoughts on the BB indictment that's on
yesterday's show also did you take on
the bolivian coup result in major
backlash it resulted in major backlash
mostly from people who were not already
in my audience to tell you the truth we
addressed this actually let me preview
something for you guys I think you might
enjoy this let me see if I can find this
away that's efficient I got a call too
we recorded calls early this week
because we're going to be on break for
vacation I got a call today confronting
me about Bolivia and putting in front of
me the position of secular talks Kyle
kolinsky and I imploded under pressure
no not really but I'll play the call for
you this happened earlier today and it
won't be published for a while but why
not let's let's take a look at it if
this works let's see here here we go
let's go next to our caller from the
8:03 area code who is calling today from
8:03 so this was earlier today but it
will not air for a while I'm just
showing it to you today hello David hi
who's this Bolivia and Venezuela and I
see that you know you criticize what you
call the Leninist less and I've watched
both you and secular talk and you seem
to have different views about US
intervention there although you know you
definitely don't do cons so my question
is what are your thoughts on like
historical cases like the US
intervention of Chile at 1973 yeah I'm
against US intervention in Latin America
so what I I don't I don't watch any
other shows so what my position is I'm
against US intervention in Bolivia and
Venezuela what's Kyle's position he's
much more in defence of the Venezuelan
and Bolivian government although he does
have some very strong criticism of
Nicolas Maduro
so and so and he's against US
intervention there right yeah okay yeah
so am i all right do you think that Ava
Morales was a dictator no dictator is
not the right word but he certainly was
not you know he's not the strongest
advocate for democracy that Latin
America has seen let's put it that way
all right thank you all right thank you
very much appreciate the phone call
alright so there it is I think that that
is where we can maybe leave the Bolivia
stuff at this point in time thanks to
Lord Jabberwock for subscribing with
twitch Prime and thanks to Zahra chef
ski for subscribing with twitch Prime as
well
questions pouring in over on YouTube
Tyler shank asking candidates you think
will drop before Iowa votes well I'll
tell you who I think should drop let's
look at the list let's see here
so I don't even know if all these people
are still running Sestak gotta go he
should he has no role in this Bullock
time to go Delaney should get out I
thought he was out then it should get
out steyr should have gotten in he
should absolutely be out who Leon Castro
probably should get out cory booker
probably should get out Tulsi Gabbard
probably should get out and Amy
Klobuchar should get out
I doubt Klobuchar and Gabbard will get
out I wouldn't be surprised if everyone
from Booker down gets out before the
first votes but Klobuchar and Gabbard
you know Klobuchar was propped up with
more speaking time than she then her
polling suggests she should get during
the MSNBC debate it seems Klobuchar is
kind of a favorite of the corporate
media prop up establishment Democrats
Tulsi Gabbard I think is just going to
stay in because she just seems to be
doing the opposite of everything that
makes sense so I assume she'll stay in
but but I wouldn't be surprised if
everyone from Booker and below get out
before the first ballots are cast and
again people are asking are all these
people still running
I thought Delaney was not running
anymore I thought Bennett wasn't running
anymore obviously they're not making the
so I don't know the answer to that but
that's sort of where I'm at Andy Ramos
says monies thank you I appreciate that
message and then Andy Ramos again says
more monies Sam Dean says good day I'll
dive on the grenade and keep an eye on
the Trump rally oh I didn't know that
there was a live Trump rally let's
actually see if we can find that let's
go next to our caller from Trump rally
oh let's see what's going on we have to
see this oh boy okay we'll get to that
in a second let me just say another
thank you to Scott Speer Scott Speer has
signed up at join pakman.com but not
using either coupon code there's a
twitch fifty coupon code for people on
twitch to use to score a point for
twitch oh this thing hasn't even started
yet
there is a youtube fifty coupon code for
YouTube viewers to use we have a
competition going I know it's not much
of one it's one to one we've had three
people sign up today one without a
coupon who what is going on here what is
coming and I have a special gift for you
but I cannot show you okay so things
getting very very weird there so anyway
listen join pakman.com is where you sign
we get 12 more members I'll open up the
phone lines if you're watching on
YouTube sign up with YouTube 50 to score
a point for YouTube if you're watching
on twitch sign up with twitch 50 both
codes save you 50% there's no advantage
to one or the other other than do you
want to say YouTube is better or do you
want to say twitch is better that's all
that that is so I think we've gotten
that out of the way this is so now we've
lost the feed altogether let's refresh
and see what's going on very strange
things happening over here yeah I don't
know what's going on
hmm
okay now it's refreshing
yeah who knows what's going on here I
don't know anyway we'll give it a second
and see if we can get get back to that
I'm still alive right it seems as though
I'm live am i not live hmmm
looks like we're back that was weird
yeah I don't know what happened there
you know I think there's something weird
going on I'm not sure in any case all
right I'll try to take a few more
questions here and and continue we'll
keep an eye on what's going on here ARS
longa says his Artie Russian propaganda
well yeah I mean it's it's a state it's
state you know you propaganda doesn't
have to be negative and it certainly
certainly is propaganda in a sense ego
Equis says Buddha judge has the Mondale
Dukakis Edwards
energy that Democrats are so good at
cultivating yes there there is an
element of that for sure not Yancey says
spending my youtube money you're welcome
thank you
fave one says Trump tweeted today I held
back the money from Ukraine because it
is considered a corrupt country so he
admitted he held up the money and it was
for corruption oh yeah yeah we talked
about that yesterday we talked about
that yesterday there's no question about
that
JC is asking will I debate Aaron maté on
impeachment I don't know I have no idea
I'm pretty busy with my own thing a DD
says what drummer influenced you the
most I don't know that any one drummer
influenced me the most but you know I
love Steve Gadd Vinnie Colaiuta the
great John Bonham is of course amazing I
could go on and on and on Neil Peart is
a great drummer yeah I think I think
we're back let's see if this guy's back
ok perfect
I'll call you guys back when she's in
front of the camera it looks like we're
seeing some kind of producer it's ok
that's weird I don't think there's I
don't even think they're trying to air
this and I'm rebroadcasting it it's all
very very weird ok I don't know what's
going on
Tyler shank has signed up with the code
youtube' 50 that's new member number 4
of the evening and that puts YouTube
ahead of twitch 2 to 1 I was really
thinking twitch might be able to hold it
together today and come away with a win
but
YouTube still still in the lead two to
one
we are waiting for Donald Trump at some
rally somewhere let me refresh this and
see if I can get the information about
where this is happening Trump holds a
homecoming campaign rally in Florida
expected live at 7:10 p.m. okay so I
guess we're 10 minutes away from the
start of this very bizarre press
conference for people saying twitch 50
didn't work let me let me look at that I
think it does work let me see sign up
twitch 50 it works there's no space
between twitch and 50 so people want the
feed volume
yeah I don't know that we need to really
be hearing that yet which 50 is working
there's just no space between the two
but that's all what's going on there
okay let me answer a few other questions
here craft Punk asks if I made my intro
music no a viewer whose handle is curtly
Jay made our intro music let me see here
21st century Mouse says David be honest
was debating creationist cat the
highlight of your career absolutely
absolutely
kane raven lock says about RT what
happened to them so much conspiracy
coverage now i haven't seen anything on
RT for probably the better part of two
years so i really I shouldn't speak to
what they're doing because I haven't
seen it and then Robert Williams says
because I like independent media thank
you so much I really do appreciate that
we were waiting for Donald Trump in
Florida it is probably going to be
another one of these upper laced Magga
rallies usually Trump at the evening
rallies is pretty well you know I think
I think we you guys know what I'm
talking about so we're waiting for Trump
to arrive seems like is this armed
security do these guys have weapons back
here it's Florida right so everybody
should be armed you but you would think
I guess now it looks like maybe it's uh
maybe those are tasers or something like
that
this is the guy you really want running
security in case there's an issue this
is the guy who's gonna hold it down
so anyway yeah well it looks like we're
about eight minutes away and I'm looking
forward to seeing what what happens
there let me say a few other thank-yous
before I forget tan man subscribed for
four months at Tier one I appreciate
that
bad reaction thanks for the twitch Prime
subscription and PQ Rocksteady thank you
for subscribing for one month at tier
one thank you very much
let me answer a couple of other
questions tyler shank saying we're
taking a weird trip to trump ville right
now yeah I've never covered a trump it's
just never happened that when I'm
streaming I'm aware of a trump rally
happening in real time so I'm actually
curious what is what's going to happen
this isn't Carter page is it that was
weird it sort of looked like him oh
don't tell me that there's a Jewish guy
here it is so every time I see that
there's a Jewish Trump supporter I'm
extra sickened because it's you know one
of my people it's just so depressing
it's like what are you doing what are
you doing okay looks like they got the
main camera back here so we should be
getting started pretty soon fave one
saying how do so many people turn up to
these Trump rallies the impeachment
hearings exposed again how incompetent
and corrupt the Trump administration is
it's a country of three hundred and
forty million people you can convince
tens of millions that Trump is corrupt
you're still gonna get you know eight
thousand to fill a third of a stadium if
that's what you want ARAG --mess says
free super chat happy birthday it is not
my birthday for a while but it is it's
starting to get closer so I still
appreciate that oh my is this music
they're going to get sued for
oh dear anybody know what we're
listening to is that likely an artist
who hates Trump and will soon send a
cease-and-desist as often happens
anybody know yeah I have no idea what
what music that is oh let me block a few
people cuz there are some people who are
just being absolutely toxic so let me
block a few people over on Twitch and
then also block a few people over on
YouTube because it's just
oh that's Tina Turner okay very good
yeah it's free to ban people and we will
we will not hesitate to do that big Luna
thanks for subscribing with twitch prime
Stefan row thanks for subscribing for
the second month in a row with twitch
prime I appreciate that
Nouvel coasts asks you often ask for
audience feedback stating you're open to
having your mind changed what are recent
examples of feedback markedly changing
your views so here's an example of
something I recently evolved on about
six months ago I was under the
impression that the financial case for
medicare-for-all
was 110 percent open-and-shut like the
math obviously works in the last six
months I've seen more and more studies
which say that the math could work but
most of the most of the budgets assume
that we drastically reduce healthcare
spending per capita to the level of
Australia and Canada and merely
switching to a single-payer system is
not going to achieve that it could take
depending on the estimates anywhere from
8 to 20 years to make that happen and so
that is something that I have fleshed
out my view on and I have a different
view today than I did six months ago
that's an example austin Biddinger says
hey happy birthday David via superjet
thank you it is not my birthday but I do
appreciate that no matter what let's see
oh there's someone who is asking for a
ban and calling me a Zionist shill no
problem glad to oblige let's see here JC
says do you think the hill is acting in
good faith when they cover impeachment
and the Moller
investigation don't know I've not seen
any of their coverage so I would not I
would not be able to say thanks to
Finnegan 1717 for subscribing with
twitch Prime I appreciate that very much
question will there be someone in the
audience in this area in Trump's sight
line with an antagonistic sign that they
have snuck in we can only hope but that
would be absolutely delightful a people
on both twitch and YouTube cheering that
the banhammer is coming down yeah it is
it is i i've deputized moderators on
both twitch and YouTube to ban as they
see appropriate based on very specific
directions that I've given and I
appreciate that that's happening so for
people asking do I no longer support
medicare-for-all no no even if the
numbers don't add up as cleanly as I
believe they did six months ago it can
still be our best plan and it would
obviously be better than what we have
nuanced nuanced Oh should I mute it
because the music we might have a
copyright issue yeah I'll mute it I'll
mute it for now that's a good idea we
should be only about four minutes from
Trump speaking although who knows who
knows
Shawn Geiss asking her if they're going
to zoom out here to show empty seats I
don't think that they will I don't think
that they will that's not usually that
the way they do it
Travis Hallman is asking if I have any
concerns about medicare-for-all in terms
of a loss of privacy no because in
medicare-for-all the government does not
become the provider HIPPA still would
exist the the government becomes the
payer all right let's see what's going
on here
oh no okay there is no way that Led
Zeppelin is okay with Donald Trump using
their music there's just no way that
that is a possibility but we're going to
keep it down yeah this is there there
this is very reminiscent of totalitarian
rallies thanks to torpedo Marcus to
torpedo supermarket who is gifting subs
over on Twitch like crazy I appreciate
that very very much
people continuing to ask about opening
up the phone lines I don't know that
it's going to happen we have 4 of 15
website members the target is 15 and
then we will open up phone lines and
it's not going super well today join
pakman.com is the place to sign up I
will just wet your whistle with some
voicemails though people trying to call
in but failing because the voice of the
voicemail is currently on calls are
being redirected to voicemail I might be
able to play a couple of these for you
before Trump speaks let's take a listen
here's one example
yes David Elliot from Florida I want you
to know your observation about the
president and his hospital visit we give
you some news based on my observation
thing here two elderly parents as I
mentioned the whole nine yards he shows
all the signs and then I find out he's
snorting adderall right definitely the
signs of that this man won't see a year
as far as I'm concerned I think nature's
gonna take its course that Admiral stuff
will definitely screw up my daughter was
on and I took her off it changes your
personality no question about it by the
way I'm an idiot
I recognized that that that was
Aerosmith not Led Zeppelin and that's
just me being old and yes I know
Aerosmith is from Boston and there is no
way Steven Tyler supports Donald Trump
are things happening because people are
now are people being asked to stand I'm
guessing that that's what they do people
probably would not naturally stand but
it's intimidating
fastest time oh okay let's listen to
here's a voicemail from my old stomping
grounds two four one three area code
David I just had a question for you you
talked about it several shows ago as far
as legalization of drugs or
decriminalization of drugs you sort of
indicated that you would be in favor of
decriminalizing and legalizing some
drugs but not others and I was just
curious as to what your thinking was on
that no so my view is that I'm for
decriminalizing everything
and I'm open to being convinced about
legalizing something like cocaine or
heroin I've just not yet seen a great
case for that but I want to
decriminalize everything
I think obviously cannabis should be
legalized recreationally and there are
others as well let's see oh ok let me do
a couple thank you so thanks to Eyal my
ok
Eyal maokai subscribing for twitch prime
and 56 kona dial up for subscribing with
twitch prime as well as Juris
pretentious I appreciate that Sam Dean
over on YouTube super chat says there's
no way Tina Turner gave Trump permission
to use her music that she even know she
should be furious can we find her
lettuce tweet I I agree with that that
should be that should be done oh people
are asking over on Twitch if highlighted
messages can count like twitch super
chat let's do it I like that I like that
idea the answer is yes they can one of
the questions is will I be chatting with
destiny he's chilling doing nothing big
not today oh here's Mike Pence okay and
the music that they probably shouldn't
be using continues so we'll hear from
pence momentarily let me see what other
questions have come in there are a lot
of them some of them more logical than
others Jerry Todd says paying for a
comment for the first time in my life so
I can tell you I'm still gonna watch you
even though you didn't know that song
was Tina Turner thank you I appreciate
that let's listen to Mike I I'll just
have to delete the streams I can't do
anything the music is just persistent
[Applause]
Wow
[Laughter]
let's just give him a second and maybe
the music will come off no it's not
Pence is looking robotic
it is great to be back in the Sunshine
State
[Applause]
great to be here to welcome home one of
Florida's newest residents yeah
to save on taxes loser folks I'm here
for one reason
[Music]
yes evangelical churches Florida and
America need four more years of
President Donald Trump so I was
wondering if they were going to
transition into just basically
re-election at this point and it looks
like they are
[Applause]
strategic placement of a black guy over
Pence's left shoulder oh sorry I just
when this president stands up for
American jobs and American workers I
stand with President Donald Trump when
this president stands up for faith and
freedom and our armed forces I stand
with President Donald Trump this
position is basically reserved for a
black person during any Trump rally like
this camera position I'm sure that
there's like a piece of tape on the
ground and they see they go this is
where we have to have a black eye
standing with President Donald Trump you
know what began four years ago has grown
into a movement a movement of everyday
Americans from every walk of life here
in Florida you believed we could be
strong again right you believed we could
be prosperous again and Florida
Republicans were with us every step of
the way and not just all of you but all
your great leaders like governor Ron de
santis
lieutenant-governor Jeanette Nunez
Attorney General Ashley Moody no one
knows who these people are your former
attorney general the great and on
blondie totally correct
kooky and corrupt and let's hear it for
Florida's great delegation to the
Congress of the United States and the
United States Senate with their support
and your support Florida said yes to
President Donald Trump in 2016 and I
know you're gonna say yes to four more
years and president Donald Trump back to
the White House in 2020 right you know
there's only one way I think you can
describe the last three years I agree
embarrassing it's been three years of
action it's been three years of results
I'm noticing this guy's physical
appearance is unnerving I mean think
about it
this president promised to rebuild our
military restore the arsenal democracy
and stand by our troops and President
Donald Trump as your commander-in-chief
has done just that and he signed the
largest investment in our national
defense since the days of Ronald Reagan
[Applause]
and with that renewed American strength
we've taken the fight to radical Islamic
terrorists on our Islamic on their soil
in the last year alone American forces
captured the last inch of the Isis
Caliphate in Syria I know this is
riveting but I do want to thank Matthew
Van Zeeland for signing up at join
pakman.com with the code twich 50 that
gets us five new members this evening
and it is tied two to two because one
person didn't use a code youtube' to
twitch to the battle is on oh not again
not again with the dog
you know last weekend Karen and I
visited our military in Iraq it's a
great privilege and we told them what
all of you already know the Armed Forces
of the United States are the greatest
force for good the world has ever known
some folks would question that notion
and our troops know they have a
commander-in-chief who will always have
their back Trump has been one of the
worst presidents to the military it's
it's truly actually stunning that they
continue to fall for this nonsense that
you earned in the uniform of the United
States and President Donald Trump
delivered we reformed the VA and
veterans Choice is now available to
every veteran in America no one knows
what that is and it's not true
and this president promised to secure
our borders we've made historic
investments in border security
apprehensions on our southern border are
down by 70% and we've already started
you know it's funny if apprehensions on
the southern border are up they say
they're doing a better job of catching
people if apprehensions on the southern
border are down they claim it's because
they're doing other things so that fewer
people attempt to come through it's one
of those things where it doesn't matter
what's going on they claim that it's
evidence of them doing a great job no
matter what walls not getting built
obviously and president Donald trum
delivered we've already seen this
president appoint more than a hundred
and sixty principled conservatives to
our federal courts and they're all men
and women who will uphold all the
god-given liberties enshrined in our
Constitution that's true and it's
dangerous the freedom of speech and the
Second Amendment right to keep and bear
are truly a bad person that we're
dealing with here and I couldn't be more
proud to serve as vice president to a
president who stands without apology for
the sanctity of human life
Trump was pro-choice his entire life and
took the pro-life position to become the
Republican nominee and it's about jobs
jobs jobs from the first day of our
administration President Trump has
worked to revive the American economy we
cut taxes we rolled back red tape at a
historic level we unleashed American
energy fought for free and fair trade
and America's economy is booming it's
amazing since Election Day 2016 six
point seven million new jobs created by
businesses all across this country
unemployment has hit a 50-year low the
stock market is soaring and more
Americans are working today than ever
before in the history of this country
more Americans okay let's explain that
one that's a good one too just two we
don't care really what pen says let me
explain that one to you this is a game
that they play if there's a Democratic
president they say more people than ever
are out of work right now more people
out of out of the workforce if there's a
Republican president they say more
people than ever are in the workforce
right now now the reality is that as the
population grows if the ratio stays
roughly even at all times you have a
record number of people working and a
record number of people not working
that's called population growth it's one
of the silliest games that they play
[Applause]
these two guys are just a delight you
can tell I mean think about four more
years means more jobs
four more years means more judges four
more years means more support for our
troops and it's going to take at least
four more years to drain that swamp now
he claims that's an eight year job at
first we were told it would be done
within the first year
you know the choice in this election
couldn't be clearer and the stakes
couldn't be higher today we have a
president who loves this country who
stands by our military's our workers and
our freedoms I can tell you firsthand he
never quits he never backs down you know
a lot of people in the chat on both
twitch and YouTube are saying that that
this is sad it really is sad I mean it's
sad that so many people in this country
are this appliable that they fall for
this stuff it's it truly is sad I mean
today's Democratic Party has been taken
over by radical leftists who want higher
taxes open borders late-term abortions
and socialist policies it would crush
nobody wants late term abortions
ridiculous and worst of all these do not
the Democrats have spent the last three
years on endless investigations trying
to overturn the will of the American
people they're back at it again
you know I think the Democrats were
running down this president because they
know they can't run against this
president they're radical in that they
want everyone to have health care they
can't run against his record they can't
run against our results they're pushing
their partisan impeachment because they
know they can't stop you from giving
President Donald Trump four more years
in the White House
[Applause]
yeah via super chat I was asked whether
I think pence believes the stuff he's
saying I actually don't think he does I
think deep down Trump thinks that he
believed deep down pence thinks Trump is
a disaster but for different reasons
than you and I do
I think pence doesn't like Trump because
he knows Trump's not really a religious
nut like pence let me say thanks to
Nicole Emmerich for signing up with the
coupon code youtube
also Manuel Honda for signing up without
any of these coupon codes we have 7 of
15 website members and YouTube has taken
the lead now 3 2 to keep voicing your
support keep telling your friends and
neighbors that America needs four more
years of President Donald Trump in the
White House and we will get this done in
November of 2020 we got work to do I'm
gonna take all of us to do it we're
gonna get it done
because I have faith faith in this
president that's weird my friend who's
drive and vision I see every day who's
drive and vision have made America great
again faith in all of you and all of our
fellow Americans who know we can make
America greater than ever before and
lastly I have faith that he who's
blessed this nation every day oh dear
since that oh there's a woman with a
Jesus shirt putting her hand up that we
could ask or imagine beautiful so ladies
and gentlemen thank you for coming out
today I can tell you President Donald
Trump is the real deal
believe me he's a man who says what he
means and means what he says
oh they're zooming out so you can see a
whole row of black people that they've
crowbarred into the rally and I know
that with your continued support with
our strong allies from your Statehouse
to the nation's capitol with President
Donald Trump in the White House for four
more years and with God's help yeah
we're going to keep on winning we're
gonna deliver a great future for the
American people and together with this
man
we will keep America great so now it's
my high honor CagA and distinct
privilege to introduce to you my friend
and the 45th president of the United
States of America President Donald Trump
[Applause]
God Wow let's turn that down for a
little bit yeah I this I haven't
actually watched an entire one of these
in total and it is really depressing for
what it says about the United States I
mean it really really is depressing it's
it is shocking and look at this guy
yeah I don't know I'm sort of at a loss
for words because it's all so odd and
and sad I mean it's a you know Latinos
for Trump blacks for Trump it's it's all
just look at all these kids they've been
totally brainwashed it's it's
unbelievable this woman seems completely
taken with Trump which is scary and
Toronto's Trump's getting out Hackett is
giving out hats question via 2,500
Icelandic kroner I don't know what I'm
gonna do with my spare time when Trump
is impeached maybe go back to watching
Big Bang Theory ya know it's what when
whenever he leaves it's gonna be a big
it's gonna be a big change for all of us
Chris Lopez is asking how many people
were paid to be there let me say thanks
to perturb perturb a bow per table 0:08
for subscribing with twitch prime I very
much appreciate that they're doing the
handshake yeah oh my goodness
dispense livre just stand back there I
guess he leaves he's probably sick of
this nonsense
Wow
yep there it is oh and it's still going
this is so crazy this is just I've not
watched an entire one of these and it is
really sickening I mean real I don't
know how reporters I'd have to travel
around and go to a bunch of these do it
I guess you get desensitized to it like
anything else no no but it's really
really bad
pointing more pointing at people yeah
when Trump was starting out the hats
it's funny that Lazarus mentioned this
on to twitch chat I was reminded of when
Trump went to Puerto Rico after a
hurricane and started shooting paper
towel rolls at people like it was a game
like they were having a good time
which will he mention first crowd sighs
polling or the witch-hunt and thank you
to the great state of Florida thank you
[Applause]
so less than one year from now I will
join voters across the Sunshine State my
home imagine that and together we will
win back the house we will hold the
Senate and we will keep that beautiful
beautiful White House I have the audio
maxed out by the way I can't I can't do
any minute for you stock market just hit
another all time in history high meaning
401k does nothing for most of the people
in that crowd I'm sure oh I like Florida
I love my young lady make sure as you
know you have a great governor we're
very happy with Ronnie's doing a
fantastic job but make sure you register
to vote as we gather together for
Thanksgiving you know some people want
to change the name Thanksgiving they
don't want to use the term who's that
and that was true also with Christmas
but now everybody's using Christmas who
wanted to change the name of Christmas I
want to say somebody please tell me who
wanted to change the name
oh my god but Americans have so much to
be thankful for the economy is booming
wages are rising crime is falling
poverty is plummeting confidence is sir
and America is stronger than ever before
it's true he says I like having
clarifies actually true we've created
6.7 million new jobs including 600,000
jobs right here in the great state of
Florida we're protecting American
workers taking care of our amazing
veterans by the way you know the
veterans for years and years and years I
was like I would lie about donating to
them I wasn't the president but I'd
always see you turn on the news you read
in the paper about our veterans being
mistreated by you they were doing such a
poor job you don't hear that anymore do
you you don't hear it anymore our
veterans for the first time are taken
care of to a level can you imagine being
so delusional that you believe that can
you really imagine well let this school
is going nuts and maybe most importantly
right now if the world the way it is we
are rebuilding the awesome power of the
United States military he is starting to
slur again people are noticing that he
is his s's are starting to become a
little bit shifty 2.5 trillion dollars
and everything is made right here in the
USA
we make the greatest equipment in the
world and a few weeks ago US Special
Forces the world's number one terrorist
to justice
the bloodthirsty savage known as
al-baghdadi is dead bloodthirsty Savage
did he someone's telling me that at the
beginning Trump said vise pressures and
French but I didn't hear that this week
I stuck up for three great warriors
against the deep state oh my goodness
he's doing conspiracy he believes that
by pardoning war criminals he's fighting
the deep state people have to be able to
fight these are great warriors they
can't think gee whiz if I make a mistake
do I go for you do I mean you know what
they were doing they wanted to put him
in jail for 25 years one young man was
in jail for seven years he had 16 more
years to go
and I want to tell you when you look at
what they did to that man you would have
been very proud at what we ended up
doing he came out he hugged his parents
it was even murderers hug their parents
if they get out of prison early